The SCP Foundation is home to plenty of anomalies
whose reputations precede them.
Here at SCP Explained, we've discussed quite
a few of the most notable anomalies contained
by the Foundation, from the wholesome half-cats
and Tickle Monsters to the nightmarish giant
reptiles and reality-warping old men . But
there are very few anomalies so popular, so
famous - or infamous, depending on who you
ask - that they attract a nonstop revolving
door of would-be worshippers to sew chaos
all around the Foundation.
What's it like to be a creature that's always
the center of attention, whether he wants
to be or not?
Today we're looking at the lifestyle of the
involuntarily famous, SCP-2662.
We took the liberty of observing a full day
in the life of the entity known by many as
Cthulhu, from his morning routine to his bedtime,
and all the little moments of unplanned chaos
in between.
With his permission, we compiled everything
we saw into a video for your entertainment!
Welcome to A Day in the Life of SCP-2662.
9:00 AM
Time to wake up, stretch your tentacles, and
get ready for the day ahead!
At a respectable, not-too-early and not-too-late
time, usually around 9 AM but sometimes a
little bit later if he's had a particularly
late night, SCP-2662 climbs out of bed and
uses his computer to throw on one of his favorite
podcasts.
Preferred topics for listening include game
reviews and news, comedic advice podcasts,
and daily news roundups.
What he eats for breakfast depends on the
day, but his favorite morning meals are pancakes
and huevos rancheros.
No matter what he's eating, he washes it down
with a tall glass of orange juice.
His nutrition needs aren't like those of a
human, but it's important to start the day
with a tasty meal no matter what.
It's the little things that make life worth
living.
While he eats his breakfast, he reads a newspaper,
brought to him by the Foundation staff each
morning according to his request.
The publication varies, but no matter what,
his favorite section is Arts and Style or
Human Interest.
He always reads the whole thing from front
to back, though, even the obituaries and wedding
announcements.
He only gets one a day, after all, and he
knows it's important to appreciate things
to their fullest extent and take nothing for
granted.
10:00 AM.
Now it's time for SCP-2662's day to really
get going.
He hops in the shower and listens to another
podcast as he warms up- literally, he likes
the water to be as hot as the Foundation will
allow before they complain about the utility
bill.
After he dries off, he gets a hankering for
a little bit of gaming.
Just as he starts to settle into his gaming
chair and look through his library of video
games, a member of Task Force Tau-9 knocks
on the door to his containment room.
"Hey, are you busy?"
"Not really, something going on?"
"Yeah...we're just keeping an eye on a couple
religious groups of interest.
According to the chatter on the forums, and
a few of the leaders' social media accounts,
they might be planning something disruptive.
Lots of posts about a "Day of Great Freedom"
and "Unleashing the Lord of Madness Upon the
Pathetic World."
Cthulhu sighs.
"Must be a day that ends in 'Y'."
"Sorry, buddy."
The officer shrugs, not sure what else to
say.
Clearly the two of them have spent their fair
share of days fending off mad cultists.
"You know the drill, if anyone who's not supposed
to be here shows up, starts sacrificing goats
and such, just let us know.
Hopefully, it won't come to that, we should
stop them before they get that far."
"Hope so.
Last time they got blood everywhere, and broke
my disk copy of Resident Evil 4."
12:00 PM.
Time flies when you're having fun, and when
you're pacing back and forth, worried about
cultists breaking in to bother you with who
knows what.
Before long, it's 12:00, and that means lunchtime!
When it comes to lunch, SCP-2662 has simple
tastes.
He likes a good old grilled cheese and tomato
soup, a bean burrito, or a steaming bowl of
ramen.
With that, he's partial to a sugary soda,
or sometimes a lemonade.
He often likes to tune into gaming streams
on Twitch, especially obscure indie titles,
or, if he's feeling like something a bit more
familiar, Minecraft.
But on this particular day, he has a visitor!
SCP-507, the Reluctant Dimension Hopper, has
swung by with his own lunch to have a catch-up
chat.
A huge fan of meeting other friendly anomalies,
especially those completely different from
himself, SCP-507 often stops by Cthulhu's
containment room whenever he happens to be
in the same dimension.
"Hey Squidward, how's it going?"
SCP-2662 hasn't seen the show that this particular
nickname came from, but he enjoys being called
a friendly name instead of some manner of
esoteric title.
During this visit, SCP-507 shares stories
of his recent travels with SCP-2662, including
his recent disturbing brush with the Smiling
Man, and his much more delightful time in
a dimension where he found himself on a beach
where the sand was made of popcorn and the
sea was made of Coca Cola.
"Any weird cults come by lately?"
He asks, after finishing his story.
"Not in a few weeks, tentacles crossed it
stays that way.
But you know my luck!
Someone will probably be drawing arcane symbols
on the walls and doing weird chants in no
time."
"Bummer." 507 nodded sympathetically.
"Wanna play co-op for a bit?
I haven't had time in forever."
"Sure!"
Even when it's a rare treat, it's always nice
to spend time with a friend doing something
you both love.
Even if we can't relate to much about SCP-2662's
day-to-day life, we can at least relate to
that.
It doesn't have to be gaming, either.
It can be painting, baking, or even just watching
a tv show you love.
The activity doesn't matter nearly as much
as the company, after all.
1:30 PM.
After about an hour of gaming with SCP-507,
SCP-2662 gets an unwelcome interruption.
Just when the two enter a new dungeon, ready
to take on the bosses waiting in there, right
when SCP-2662 asks to be healed...SCP-507
disappears from his seat, popping over to
wherever his anomalous dimension-hopping ability
dragged him to next.
"Oh...bye."
He knows 507 can't hear him, but he wants
to bid him farewell just the same.
He turns to his computer, and boots up a game
he can play by himself.
He only hopes his friend was sent somewhere
safe, and that he'll come back sometime soon.
2:00 PM.
At 2:00, SCP-2662 gets yet another unwelcome
interruption.
A loud boom rocks the room as explosives detonate
nearby, breaking a wall of the containment
unit open.
While the Mobile Task Force does their best
to subdue the invaders responsible, they are
all knocked out by a grenade filled with an
unidentified form of sleeping gas.
With no one to deter them, a group of strange
civilians in red robes come pouring into SCP-2662's
room.
"Oh great and powerful Lord of Darkness, we
come to free you from this infernal prison!"
One man shouts, brandishing a candelabra filled
with lit black candles.
"Oh, no thanks.
I'm good here."
"But...we brought you an offering."
Another man steps forward, tossing a bag of
dried bats onto 2662's bed.
"Hey, oh man, I sleep there!
Gross."
Cthulhu groans.
"We have thirteen more offerings, and then
the sacrificial ritual can commence!
You just need to come with us so it can begin!
The day of Great Freedom, when you will unleash
your thousand year reign of madness upon the
land!"
"I'm not really into madness, I'm more into
Overwatch."
SCP-2662 backs away from the supplicants,
even as they come at him with more and more
grotesque offerings.
Cow tongues, unidentifiable mushrooms, one
woman tries to hand him a crying baby.
He refuses each one, but they are persistent.
As he is swatting away jars of pickled frogs,
a woman begins drawing a circle around the
room in what he hopes is red paint, but fears
is something else entirely.
"Um, thank you all for these gifts.
You have proven yourself as loyal followers.
I'm going to stay here though, to, uh, spread
the madness.
From here.
You all can go on home."
He tries to shoo them out, but they continue
to press closer.
Thankfully, his rescue finally shows up.
Task Force Tau-9 swoops in at this point and
begins knocking out and administering amnestics
to all of the cultists.
They may not be able to cure them of their
mad devotion, but they can at least make sure
the cult forgets the location of the containment
unit.
At least, for a little while.
They're able to dispense with these particular
intruders humanely, but they may need to use
lethal force for the next ones.
That's always a possibility.
After the cultists have been removed from
the Site, some maintenance staff are called
in to repair the damage to the wall where
the explosives knocked it in.
While they work, SCP-2662 goes over his newspaper
one more time, making sure he didn't miss
anything.
Attention to detail is an important skill
to have, especially if one intends to get
the most out of their everyday life.
He finds a few editorials he neglected to
read before, and enjoys finishing up the newspaper
in its entirety.
4:00 PM.
After the task force returns to their stations,
and the maintenance crew has finished fixing
the wall, SCP-2662 turns to one of his newest
hobbies.
He attempted to hide this pursuit from the
Foundation at first, but they agreed to let
him try it out as long as he followed some
safety precautions.
So now, at around 4 PM every day, SCP-2662
streams on his very own Twitch channel.
He never uses identifying information, and
keeps his camera turned off the entire time
lest the internet see his tentacled face,
but he does talk to the few viewers in his
chat via a microphone.
"What's up, it's SquidBoi2662, back to play
some games for you guys again.
I hope you're all having a killer day, and
thanks for tuning in.
Today I'm going to be checking out Apex Legends
for the very first time.
A lot of you recommended this game to me,
so I'm stoked to check it out!"
As his small fan community watches, SCP-2662
tries out the popular MMORPG, and plays his
way through it for several hours.
One person in the chat asks if he has ever
heard of "the great tentacled beast of legend,"
but he makes sure to block them before they
give the rest of the chat any ideas.
He doesn't want people to watch his streams
because he's some famous elder god or something,
he wants to be liked for who he is.
7:00 PM.
Every gamer needs to break for some fuel,
and SCP-2662 is no exception!
At around 7, he wraps up his stream, thanks
all of his viewers and subscribers, and gets
ready to have some dinner.
He throws on another podcast, this time an
actual play podcast following a tabletop gaming
campaign, and tucks into his last meal of
the day.
Like all of his other meals, it varies from
day to day, but most of the time he goes with
his favorite: pizza.
A big cheese pizza, delivered from a local
pizza shop by a delivery boy who has received
more than his fair share of amnestics, and
can never remember why exactly this random
unmarked building seems so familiar.
Munching on his pizza and listening to tales
of magic and mayhem acted out by a group of
friends at a game table, SCP-2662 can't help
but feel just a little melancholy.
He's happy with what he has, of course, but
he dreams of a normal life.
The kind of life where he and his friends
could play games together or record a podcast.
Where he could share this pizza with someone
else.
But he might not ever have that, and it's
something he has to accept.
He can still choose to appreciate what he
has, rather than mourn what he doesn't.
After he's finished eating, and the episode
is finished, it's back to the grind at the
computer.
He turns on The Sims for a little while, constructing
the kind of normal life he likes to fantasize
about sometimes.
But then one of his Sims burns the house down
while trying to make eggs, and he gives up
on that particular endeavor to play some Minecraft.
11 PM.
Some nights the excitement keeps SCP-2662
awake and playing his games until the wee
hours of the morning.
Tonight, however, he finds himself exhausted
from an unexpectedly action-packed day, courtesy
of those cultists.
He powers down the game, turns on his final
podcast of the day, a guided meditation to
wind him down for sleep, and climbs into bed.
Tomorrow, he'll get up and do it all again,
doing his best to carve out a little bit of
peace in a strange, chaotic world.
Maybe tomorrow he'll just be left alone, allowed
to be himself instead of what everyone expects
him to be.
He'll just have to stick it out and see.
That's the beauty of this life, after all.
Tomorrow is always a new day.
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go check out “A Day in the Life of SCP-049”
and “What Does SCP-999 Do All Day?
(Hour by Hour)” for more anomalous daily
routines!